[Musik]
total entspannt ist denn hier um die
architektur gefällt mir total gut also
ich muss sagen ich bin total positiv
aber zum wohnen auf keinen fall erste
hier im café oder zum schlendern
[Musik]
wenn man den unterschied kennt vom
technischen rathaus ziehen dann ist es
natürlich kritisch zu sehen wenn man
eine altstadt eine neue altstadt
das sagt schon irgendwie der begriff
aber es ist schön geworden wenn sie
statt 200 millionen ich würd habe ihm
unterstützung gibt es ist natürlich ein
problem wenn das nur für sehr einen sehr
exklusiven kleinen greifen den fiba
menne finanzwelt
[Musik]
zunächst richtig weh als ich in einer
ganz anderen stadt und ich bin auch so
überrascht dass es so groß geworden ist
und so dieses als ganzes ganze ensemble
ist so perfekt geradezu aber nicht sehr
genau beobachtet und fremd ist
vielleicht merkt man gar nicht was ist
jetzt eine rekonstruktion und was ist
neues gebäude also es ist insgesamt
wirklich gelungen
[Musik]
wir haben im internet recherchiert und
entdeckt dass die altstadt gestern
eröffnet wurde und habe gedacht uns die
mal an und ein bisschen spazieren das
erinnert schon mehr an so münster oder
so also ingo städte wo es wirklich eine
richtige alte altstadt gibt also mir ist
das ganze hier noch etwas golden aber
ich denke mal das wird sich sehr rasch
geben und durch die witterung
[Musik]
es kommt er noch vor wie so ein museum
weil es noch so leer ist
[Musik]
touristischer magnet ein heer von daher
ist es sicherlich nicht ganz einfach
hier zu wohnen
die lage ist natürlich gigantisch gut
aber überhaupt das jetzt so attraktiv
ist wenn man halt dann immer tausende
von touristen um sich hat ist an die
anderen noch drüber geredet welche
welchem ließen wurden würden ich bin das
eine schöne sache dass man die alte zeit
wieder aufleben lässt und ich bin halt
vor allem ist auch die kombination
zwischen altem modernen toll und das
passt super zu fangen
[Musik]